[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en proveerá plan a un
programa de radio francia internacional
y de france 24 esta semana ponemos el
foco enlaces escalada que se lleva a
cabo aquí en europa nos acompañan en
este estudio oliviero rusia politólogo
director del observatorio europeo de
think tanks bienvenido olivier hola
muchas gracias florencia ángeles
corresponsal de la radio w aquí en parís
bienvenida a florencia aplicación el
ritmo net corresponsal del diario
público y de varios medios españoles
enrique bienvenido buenos días gracias
felicitaciones la des escalade en europa
hoy en primera plana
[Música]
bueno pues los países de europa están
comenzando a reabrir a medida que
retrocede la pandemia del coronavirus
pero aún muchos tienen reglas estrictas
incluidos los toques de queda de queda
nocturnos por ejemplo aquí en francia el
des confinamiento está siendo un largo
proceso de dos meses dividido en cuatro
fases que acabará a finales de junio
otros países siguen inmersos en esos
procesos de desescalada sin dejar de
pensar en la temporada turística y su
importancia económica es el caso de
italia grecia o de españa y en otros
como en reino unido- la des escalada
avanza gracias al buen ritmo de las
vacunas y ahora sin embargo la cepa
india del virus quien introduce una
nueva incógnita y nuevos temores así que
sí esperanzas gracias a las vacunas pero
no tantas como para llegar a la
normalidad total repasemos algunas
portadas que nos deja el asunto diario
libération aquí en francia a propósito
de la reapertura de terrazas y bares
dice bares restaurantes la hora del
brindis recordemos que los
establecimientos abren sus terrazas tras
siete meses de cierre en italia y
corriere de la sera' restaurantes y
deporte la italia de italia reabren
y en bélgica una portada optimista en la
del diario le soir el verano boreal será
festivo
si todo va bien les pregunto libia creen
que esta última portada que hemos visto
lleva razón creen que el verano será
festivo
que haya ganas ganas y ganas por
supuesto se vio también el verano pasado
creo un después del primer confinamiento
de la primera crisis el pico pandémico
cuando se dio por acabado el
confinamiento y reabrieron los
restaurantes bares cines durante creo
que dos o tres meses pues la gente salió
mucho y se notaba una especie de estado
eufórico no yo creo que si hay ganas
pero tampoco nos engañemos la la crisis
no está detrás y habrá muchas
limitaciones
limitaciones en las distancias sociales
las mascarillas las vacunas hablaremos
de fue creo del del pasaporte o del
paskowitz habrá control y bueno
florencia que entendemos por licencias
festivas para este verano es decir
entendemos que movilidad libre sí que va
a ver pero la mascarilla va a seguir ahí
yo creo que hay muchas cosas que están
todavía en veremos no esto de la
mascarilla justamente porque todavía no
hay una fecha definitiva al menos en
francia sin embargo ya ayer el
presidente mano macrón decía que quizá
la íbamos a aportar hasta finales de
junio sin embargo es un hecho de que de
que vamos a tener más movilidad que hoy
en día la tendremos no de ir a los
restaurantes que ya se va a poder a
partir del 9 de junio pero también la
idea de poder salir un poco más tarde y
la idea de poder entrar a los festivales
ahora no no hay que olvidar que por
ejemplo uno de los grandes festivales de
francia el festival de caná va a ser
justamente en esta nueva etapa post
pandémica o de la primera etapa de post
pandémica porque es el un festival que
se realiza en mayo ahora será en julio y
veremos yo creo ahí como va a ser un
poquito esta reapertura
pero de que tendremos más libertad la
tendremos si las variantes no nos cortan
las alas cuáles son esas libertades que
tengamos en verano hasta dónde llegarán
creo que será unas libertades pues muy
importantes con una sensación de déjà vu
del verano pasado no hubo una bolivia de
un momento después de gran alegría y de
poder volver a los bares a todos los
espacios culturales también festivales
como el de la compañera y muchos eventos
deportivos seguramente empezaremos a ver
el público y luego también queda en duda
la cuestión de a nivel del al turismo yo
creo que será es probablemente será
parecido también al verano pasado donde
veremos mucho más turismo nacional la
gente que vive en francia y el turismo
en francia hay en francia la gente vive
en españa anna turismo en españa y por
hacer el turismo extranjero se intentará
promover pero seguramente habrá mucho
menos turismo internacional del que
podría haber antes de la pandemia sigue
habiendo un turismo nacional y países
que dependían mucho del turismo pues
verán el verano importante pero dónde
será no será comparable a la del verano
del 2019 por cierto les pregunta a los
tres días se han ido a tomar su primer
café en terraza parisina yo todavía no
pero voy al museo el sábado así que
bueno esto yo el único de esta mesa que
ya iba a tomar un café una terraza que
podemos hacer de un vino también no pasa
nada él no tomo alcohol normal un
refresco bueno como han encontrado el
ambiente en la calle porque bueno si si
habrán observado también de la calle no
tras siete meses de cierre de bares y
restaurantes
francia iniciado una etapa en la que ya
se han abierto esas terrazas no está tan
había unas ganas de yo vivo tengo la
suerte de vivir enfrente el bosque de
fans que es un bosque importante en los
límites de parís y hay mucha gente desde
hace dos días en las terrazas y mucha
gente que se reúne para festejar la
posibilidad de reunirse de nuevo y no
sólo abren los cafés abre también la
cultura en francia tras varios meses la
cultura que nos ha nutrido muchas veces
durante el confinamiento ahora de nuevo
en los cines los teatros los museos bajo
estrictos protocolos sanitarios se ha
maltratado a la cultura durante todo
este tiempo flores yo creo que es de los
actores que más ha sufrido evidentemente
el turismo como ya comentábamos pero
también la cultura ha pasado pues
realmente muy muy muy fuertes estos
meses y sobre todo el grito que tenían
de alarma diciendo a ver no se ha
comprobado que haya un contagio de todas
las salas con el uso de la mascarilla
entonces porque nos están cerrando no yo
creo que es de las de los eventos o de
los sectores mejor dicho que el gobierno
tendría más que estar atento que
esperemos fue una gran sorpresa
justamente que el miércoles también hubo
bastantes espectadores en las salas de
cine que abrieron muy tempranito yo supe
que la primera función a las 8 de la
mañana no entonces bueno ahora con los
museos también esperemos que el sábado
te sea yo el sábado voy al museo vamos a
ver cómo que tanta gente hay por el
momento había esa luz por el momento
había todavía horarios disponibles pero
yo creo que sí hay que poner ahí el
acelerador y no solamente este arte
viajara con cesc no que es de ir a la
tomarse el café al restaurante pero
también justamente de aprovechar yo creo
que de las cosas que más se extrañaron
para muchos también en un país
francia son estos eventos culturales el
que puedas ir al museo y a ver las
exposiciones que tenías la mente y pese
a toda esta reapertura enric francia
sigue teniendo toques de queda a las 9
la noche el más estricto de europa es
decir y pese a todo es aparato de
apertura pero sí porque es cierto que
los datos ahora son radiantes buenos es
verdad que los de francia nivel de
contagios
un poco menos por debajo de los 15 mil
diarios son superiores a muchos países
europeos pues es decir la situación es
frágil y es un poco peor de la que era
hace un año cuando también empezó su
confinamiento es por eso también creo
que yo creo que los gobiernos intentando
llevar a cabo un confinamiento por fases
con diferentes etapas poco a poco para
no querer precipitarse donde a veces se
converse bueno ahí se conjugan intereses
contradictorios ahora el sentido que por
un lado la el sentimiento de euforia las
ganas de ir a las terrazas de los bares
e incluso promovido por el mismo el
gobierno por ese mismo tiempo el mismo
gobierno francés que índice prudencia
eso no sé terminado hay que vigilar
hay que seguir llevando la mascarilla si
estamos un momento un poco ambiguo
la campaña de vacunación también la que
permite seguir avanzando en esas fases
pero claro aparecen nuevas incógnitas
como aparecen ahora en el reino unido
con la variante india del virus que hace
tener dudas cuanto menos dijo el otro
día boris johnson que no que el plan
desde escalada continúa pero claras
nuevas variantes van introduciendo dudas
en este en estas etapas bien pues en y
también pero porque ahí sí que no soy
para nada experto un médico y no sé muy
bien no la verdad no no podría contestar
sé que hay variantes unas más dicen o
más peligrosas o u otras más
que contaminan se reproducen con más
facilidad pero no sé muy bien no sé muy
bien y también es por eso que bueno
decían los expertos que están asesorando
al gobierno británico no es una carrera
entre las vacunas y el virus porque el
virus avanza casi 50 por ciento más
rápido que las variantes antiguas
entonces realmente también hay que ver
incluso la eficacia de las vacunas no ya
esta semana la oms se dijo que por el
momento las vacunas ayer en el mensajero
no como son pzifer y modernas e incluso
me parece que lo dijo de astrazéneca
pero bueno seguro de las a de jaén dijo
que si estaban mostrando buenos
resoluciones de las variantes es allá
digamos que es una muy buena noticia
para esos problemas de reapertura pero
creo que hace bien por ejemplo gobierno
francesa y poco a poco ir con esta
limitación y guardarse bajo la manga el
as de a ver si en algún momento la
situación se complica en algunos
municipios se puede hacer otra vez
confinamientos o medidas restrictivas
para decir confinamientos medidas
restrictivas locales lo que le pasó a la
india que abrió demasiado rápido
después de la primera fase pandémica y
lo están pagando ahora por lo cual se
entiende también que gobiernos como ha
dicho enrique en francia quieran reabrir
pero de forma progresiva y controlada
y de cara al verano y la movilidad que
les parece esa herramienta de la que
tanto se está hablando aquí en europa el
pas kobe del pasaporte sanitario aquí en
francia será utilizado para los grandes
eventos pero no para la entrada por
ejemplo en bares y restaurantes será la
herramienta que nos permita la movilidad
en europa en red sin arte sino desde el
acuerdo que hubo ayer entre la comisión
europea parlamento europeo nos parece
que es una medida que se va a extender
en los distintos países y cada país pues
quizás lo va a exigir de manera distinta
en algunos países pues después en
francia pues no se va a imponer ni en
bares ni en comercios tampoco para no
para porque es cierto que es una medida
que ha creado cierta contradicción en la
población calidad es cierto debate aquí
en francia por ejemplo su aprobación en
la asamblea nacional fue un poco
controvertida porque primero hubo un
voto en contra y ese mismo día se volvió
a repetir la votación y al final hubo
una votación a favor de una medida que
crea cierto debate pero sí que es una
medida que es un mecanismo que se vaya a
extender se va a utilizar y va a ser
sobre todo clave para viajar al final va
y es probable que también en la
existencia de este pasaporte sanitario
pueda incentivar aún más la vacunación
creemos que ahora está tomando un ritmo
en europa donde vemos que cada semana
venidos de países occidentales
centenares de miles de vacunas en
francia en españa récord de vacunación
esta semana es un récord de vacunación
probablemente y una vacunación que
después de haber sido muy lenta de en
tres primeros meses ahora vamos a un
ritmo mucho más importante claro es que
a raíz de lo que estaba comentando mi
compañero enrique la pregunta que surge
sí sí sí puede ser una buena herramienta
pero discriminatoria
sabemos que no todos los países tienen
el mismo porcentaje de vacunación
sabemos que no en todos los países
cuesta lo mismo haces una pcr es decir
puede haber discriminación dentro de la
propia medida del pasaporte cobit que si
yo creo que de cierta manera si en este
sentido como dices
quizá la europea está más es más
frecuente que te hagas un pcr aquí en
francés gratuito aquí es gratuito pero
sabemos que hay países donde vale un
ciento y pico euros totalmente como aún
exacta y entonces ahí es cuando dices
cómo voy a garantizar que yo estoy a la
libre circulación yo creo que sí está
muy limitada justamente y es
discriminatorio en ese en ese sentido
del pase sanitario ahora es una
herramienta justamente como decíamos
para que avance la vacunación y lo
estamos
antes hace un año o un perdón en marzo
están las cifras de siete de cada diez
franceses decían que no a este pasaporte
sanitario y ahora prácticamente al revés
68 por ciento dice que sí vamos a seguir
hablando de toda la desde escala de aquí
en europa pero vamos a hacer la vuelta
de pausa quien en primera plana
[Música]
sus historias inspiran el futuro su día
a día es la actualidad su cultura sus
luchas sus éxitos y están en el corazón
de nuestros programas les contamos los
que hicieron américa latina y los que la
construyen hoy les contamos un mundo
hecho día a día por los que lo habitan
liberté égalité actual y ti
descubre las historias de la gente con
nuestros reporteros por todo el planeta
cada semana reporteros le trae una
historia inédita acompáñenos en
reporteros en cada semana por france 24
y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
continuamos aquí en primera plana de
radio francia internacional y de francés
24 esta semana con el politólogo libio
root y los mis compañeros corresponsales
periodistas florencia ángeles y enrique
bonet hablamos de la des escalada en
europa antes de irnos a la pausa
hablábamos de esa herramienta que era el
pasaporte cobit que en la que tenemos
las esperanzas para podernos mover
libremente por la unión europea este
verano y les estaba preguntando si puede
ser una herramienta discriminatoria para
públicos por ejemplo el líber que no
hayan podido tener acceso a la vacuna y
que tengan que estar viajando por
ejemplo invirtiendo dinero en un test
pcr cuando no valen lo mismo en todos
los países decir una herramienta que nos
da esperanza pero que a la vez suscita
dura dudas sobre si puede ser
discriminatoria clase plantea muchas
preguntas
yo digo más que en sus objetivos sobre
todo en sus moda y modalidades prácticas
en su logística primero porque no todos
los países lo acabamos de decir llevan
la campaña de vacunación
al mismo nivel a2 porque plantea también
dudas sobre
aspectos relativos al control de datos
que se podrían encontrar en el sanitario
o en el pasaporte sanitario entonces hay
una especie de digamos de que habría que
compaginar la dimensión de seguridad con
la de libertad no es decir como combina
seguridad que es una obligación del
gobierno de los gobiernos con la de la
libertad que es también obligación de
los gobiernos al menos en los países
democráticos liberales entonces es es
complicado es complicado de momento y
genera bastante dudas en mucha gente
esta dicotomía a la que se refiere
aliviar entre seguridad y libertad nos
está acompañando si se dan cuenta
durante toda la crisis sanitaria pero va
tomando diferentes formas ahora es el
pasar el paskowitz pero antes fueron
pues de abrir los bares es decir siempre
es esa dicotomía entre seguridad y
libertad que tenemos en todas en todas
la crisis florencia es discriminatorio
pero necesario a veces a ver si es
necesario tener una herramienta
pero también nos preguntamos hasta dónde
es efectiva por ejemplo se ha dicho que
va a ser este pasaporte sanitario ya en
vigor a partir de finales de junio al
menos en europa pero queda la duda por
ejemplo si aún con tu pase sanitario con
tu vacuna por ejemplo tienes que
presentar un pcr negativo no en teoría
no ya han dicho que no pero sabemos y
queda la duda hasta donde la vacuna es
eficaz para un contagio sabemos que
previenen formas graves de la enfermedad
y que vayas al hospital y que incluso
falles cash pero que tanto o no tú eres
portador o no de este virus con la
vacuna entonces el pase sanitario vivo
porque es una prueba pienso que las
cosas van poco a poco hace un año no
teníamos ninguna herramienta no salvo la
mascarilla de disociación social que
también hay que yo creo que los
gobiernos tienen que hacer este hincapié
en que aunque tengas la vacuna aunque
tengas este pasaporte sanitario no te
impide que no tengas que guardar cierto
respeto por esta estos gestos barrera y
una responsabilidad colectiva en cuanto
a los turistas de fuera de la unión
europea los 27 han acordado la
reapertura de fronteras a los turistas
extracomunitarios que ya hayan sido
vacunados la única condición será que
las
que les han administrado cuentan con el
visto bueno de la agencia europea del
medicamento lo comentaba antes mi
compañera florencia faisem moderna
astrazéneca o jansen los turistas
foráneos deberán haber recibido la pauta
completa al menos 14 días antes de su
llegada y también puede ser
discriminatorio pero el turismo y querrá
lanzarlo enrique volvemos a la dicotomía
entre relanzar la economía y medidas
discriminatorias pero al final que vamos
la temporada turística y hay países
europeos que no pueden prescindir de
ella y sixto y países europeos que casi
dependen de ello no por ejemplo grecia
que es el país en europa que quien puso
este pasaporte sanitario españa italia
incluso francia no creo que
económicamente nos afrontamos a un
periodo muy importante porque el primer
trimestre aún no hubo recesión económica
en europa y ahora a partir de este
tercer trimestre y el cuarto muy
importante es este segundo también será
importante ver cómo como ha quedado de
ver como la economía se recupera porque
hay que empezar a ver la recuperación
económica está vinculada a la situación
sanitaria que yo creo que más incluso
más importante que el verano que es más
o menos un poco más ahora es previsible
siendo
porque esto es con lo que es más
previsible el otoño como vamos a estar
en otoño y la situación como si en otoño
realmente vemos un poco la luz al final
del túnel o no eso también estará
vinculado la recuperación económica y
con comunes como empezamos a salir de
esa crisis acá mismo tiempo sitio
sanitaria económica y social esta
reapertura del turismo va asociada al
gran objetivo de la unión europea que
vuelve a asegurar que el objetivo
llegará al 70 por ciento de la población
adulta vacunada antes de que acabe el
mes de julio alcanzable
o demasiado ambicioso como lo
calificaría el 70 por ciento de toda la
población europea antes de que acabe el
mes de julio
florencia muy ambicioso pero también yo
creo va a haber es muy interesante
también que esta semana lo comentaba en
este ratito no ya logramos un récord en
un día en 24 horas tener estas
vacunaciones en francia- y yo creo que
también por eso han abierto ahora por
ejemplo para que todos los adultos se
vacunen
no está previsto para el 15 de junio lo
adelantaron para el 31 de mayo quizá
también por esto es porque están viendo
que la gente está saliendo a las
terrazas porque están viendo que tenemos
que cumplir ese objetivo no entonces por
varias razones yo creo que sobre todo
también por otra cosa porque he
preparado en junio un cargamento
absolutamente impresionante de vacunas
que es lo que va a permitir que todos en
europa y sobre todo que vienen de tipo
de rn no de facer
y a todo esto la política la política le
pregunta a nuestro politólogo dentro de
un año francia celebrará elecciones y
claro todo este contexto de reapertura
va a tener un impacto en esas elecciones
que un tema cron acabará saliendo
reforzado de toda esta crisis
no lo sé porque no creo que dependa sólo
de la crisis y de cómo se ha gestionado
le puede pasar factura y una cosa le
puede pasar factura el recuerdo bastante
ángulo angustioso y malo la mala
experiencia relacionada al confinamiento
aunque eso sí que no es culpa suya la
pandemia pero la gente puede acabar un
poco desgastada con él y su gestión
otro tema será lo que ha dicho en eric
es decir lo que va a pasar en otoño de
es decir qué va a pasar no hablo ahora
de pandemia sino de impacto a nivel
económico y ahí sí que la gente pues le
puede echar la culpa a él de no haber
tomado todas las medidas adecuadas como
para relanzar o proteger la economía y 3
porque es política va a depender mucho
de quién va a tener enfrente de él en
las elecciones esta verdadera justa de
las imágenes me hacía gracia de macro
and toman un café el otro día con su
primer ministro con jean castéra de
hasta macrón ha ido a la terraza y tú no
pero él tiene más tiempo macro no le va
a pasar factura esta crisis y sin duda
va a pesar yo creo que sea así como a
hollande se le tenía éste como etiqueta
del presidente frente a los atentados
para macro más el del presidente frente
a la crisis sanitaria y yo coincido
totalmente con los dos respecto a que
otoño es clave o sea en otoño sabremos
si hubo o no este pico bueno a lo mejor
toño pinillos de invierno no este pico
en la epidemia o no después de la
apertura en verano y finalmente también
veremos que qué más hay en la agenda de
macro no se puede tampoco delimitar a la
crisis aclaró porque a mccrone se le
puede reprochar la gestión de la crisis
o no pero claro también hay que ver y si
no quién va a capitalizar esto porque lo
que es claro de fondo está la figura de
marie le pen y de una izquierda que en
realidad no se sabe cómo puede
capitalizar de una forma de otra
a la izquierda en francia a un año de
las elecciones es una situación muy muy
debilidad muy débil dividida con
distintos vuelos verdes los socialistas
el insumiso y alúmina sión que es el
único candidato oficial la teoría la
izquierda parece una opción muy pobre
luego veremos si es bueno habrá que ver
por la izquierda es de cierto que
implante existe puede haber el
electorado izquierdas en general ahora
mismo el debate en francia está muy
derechizado se está hablando mucho en
seguridad a ti tal es pablo que puede
haber un electorado izquierdas que se
rebela un poco hacia esto y que al final
sí que termina siendo un candidato
izquierda es un poco más alto de lo que
está ahora aunque la situación a la
izquierda es mala pero fijaros qué
curioso porque en las últimas elecciones
municipales sí que hubo un triunfo de
las candidaturas psicológicas de las
candidaturas verdes o que quiso decir en
teoría o una lectura que podemos sacar
de esta crisis sanitaria la hemos
conectado con algo planetario con algo
no vamos a sacar la misma conclusión
ahora en las próximas presidenciales les
pregunto oa lo mejor es que funcionamos
de forma distinta para unas
presidenciales que para unas municipales
le preguntaron
distinta si no porque a nivel municipal
es un partido es un un grupo no que
lleva un programa a nivel presidencial
hay algún partido político detrás pero
en general se vota aquí a al menos en
este régimen muy presidencialista en
francia por una persona entonces yo creo
que la imagen que tiene la persona se
está desgastada o si genera ilusión es
casi más importante más importante que
el programa político en sí yo les
preguntaré por ampliar el debate de
francia sus respectivos países como esta
situación de esta gestión de la crisis
sanitaria repercute en sus gobiernos
hablar del caso de españa o el caso de
españa
está claro que el mismo gobierno español
le afectó al año pasado aunque más o
menos políticamente salió vivo aunque
hoy creo que los efectos de la crisis
ahora mismo el gobierno español están
afectando ahora mismo que vemos un pedro
sánchez bastante debilitado que viene de
salir de un ciclo electoral
en madrid
el debate sanitario lo marcó mucho y la
apuesta del presidente regional isabel
día no hay uso de una apuesta de como
muy la existe a nivel de restricciones
finalmente le fue muy bien el beneficio
políticamente y la situación sanitaria
que va a influir en la política haciendo
ahorita realmente tenemos también dentro
de unas semanas elecciones tanto
legislativas como municipales y de
gobernadores en algunos estados de
méxico y muchos que han dicho que van a
votar a los sondeos en muchos desde
castigó a morena justamente por la
gestión de la crisis sanitaria por parte
del presidente lópez obrador pero
también ojo porque la crisis sanitaria
ya lo hemos dicho se acompaña de la
crisis económica entonces no solamente
es no no haber hecho frente a la
pandemia o hecho frente con esas medidas
para que la gente no tuviera hospital
estuviera vacuna éxito esto sino el
apoyo a las empresas que en el caso de
méxico no hubo absolutamente lo vemos
también en colombia por ejemplo con el
presidente y bando que también ahí se le
está atacando mucho el retraso en la
campaña de vacunación a la par el quiso
también hacer esto
fiscal para que pudiéramos ellos
pudieran tener en colombia más recursos
decían y mayores impuestos para atender
justamente esa crisis económica y al
final llevan más de 20 días con
problemas de manifestaciones entonces va
ligado y va ligado en el pase de la
factura la crisis económica por la
crisis sanitaria claro que es una
situación tan inédita que ahora viene
una crisis económica que hay que
gestionar y también es inédito para
todos los gobiernos y quien va a
capitalizar en cada país las cosas
algunos se mantendrán pero está claro
que esta crisis va a acabar también con
muchos gobiernos sí
como periodistas además de decir lo
presiento estamos de un momento muy muy
incierto donde se sabe
y es cierto que es todo seguramente para
afectar a los gobiernos y con encuestas
es difícil decir si hay habrá gobiernos
que van a salir reforzados o no luego es
cierto que a nivel más a nivel general
también es probable que a nivel de uso
de modelo económico que vamos a ver
cambios estamos viendo con el 6 con
presidente vaya en un plan de
recuperación muy ambicioso incluso en
europa
la diferencia de lo que pasó en la
crisis de 2008 es clave que abra el
ciclo de la austeridad en parte se está
terminando y que se impulse más medidas
de recuperación y eso también será clave
para ver dónde nos dirigimos y si los
gobiernos sacan un beneficio político
uno bueno pues me quedo ya sintiendo
muchísimas gracias a los tres por
haberme acompañado en esta edición de en
primera plana sobre la des escalada y a
todos ustedes les esperamos aquí la
próxima semana en radio france
internacional y en france 24 muchas
gracias
[Música]